[Musique]
bonjour à tous et à toutes et j'espère
que vous aimez jouer parce que nous
allons commencer par un jeu collectif
c'est le jeu de la page dans ce jeu il y
a une balle imaginaire que vous allez
devoir vous lancer les uns aux autres le
but du jeu est que la balle passe dans
les mains de tout le monde lorsque vous
recevez la balle je vais vous demander
de lever votre main de cette manière
avec la balle pour que tout le monde
vous voit dans la salle vous êtes prêts
régisseur lumière s'il vous plaît
voici donc la balle je vais la lancer à
quelqu'un au premier rang c'est parti je
commence
vous madame qui venait de recevoir la
balle vous faites un geste de la main
c'est à votre tour lancez la balle à la
personne de votre choix dans le public
parfait vous madame qui venez de
recevoir la balle c'est à votre tour
lancez la balle
génial vous êtes extrêmement fort à vous
madame
parfait vous monsieur essayez de
l'envoyer à quelqu'un qui n'a pas reçu
de ce côté
parfait merci Monsieur alors nous allons
nous allons arrêter ce jeu maintenant
merci et vous êtes tous des toutes très
fort je suis je suis vraiment
impressionné mais je vais quand même
vous dévoiler le secret pour réussir ce
jeu à tout prix
régisseur noir dans la salle s'il vous
plaît vous avez peut-être remarqué dans
ce jeu que certaines personnes notamment
à la fin avaient plus de mal que
d'autres à rattraper la balle
ce n'était pas un problème de
coordination c'est plutôt que disons le
dernier émetteur n'avait pas regarder
précisément dans les yeux du
destinataire autrement dit si vous ne
regardez pas dans les yeux de votre
destinataire la balle va difficilement
arriver dans les mains de Monsieur
autrement dit imaginez-vous que cette
balle est en réalité une parole vous
allez parler à quelqu'un vous dit
quelque chose qui est très intéressant
cette parole doit aller à
l'interlocuteur elle doit le toucher au
point de le bouleverse si vous ne mettez
pas d'attention de votre propos votre
parole ne sert à rien à quoi vous parlez
ces personnes ne vous écoute
donc le fait de maîtriser votre langage
verbal et essentiel au quotidien je
voulais vous montrer à travers cet
exercice assez simple à quel point le
regard la gestuelle le langage non
verbal sont fondamentaux quand vous
discutez avec quelqu'un quand vous
négociez avec votre manager quand vous
parlez entre amis pendant un dîner de
famille indate au-delà des propos que
l'on tient notre corps par le lui aussi
et ils ont dit même beaucoup sur nous
le fait de maîtriser son langage verbal
et non verbal et donc fondamentale parce
qu'il vous donne un pouvoir pas
n'importe lequel le pouvoir de créer une
nouvelle opportunité le pouvoir de
découvrir une information infinie le
pouvoir de provoquer la chance mesdames
messieurs je m'appelle synasogbouti j'ai
24 ans j'étais anciennement danser à
l'Opéra de Paris puis j'ai repris les
études
je vais vous montrer à quel point la
communication devient un facteur
d'inégalité sociale majeur ensuite que
l'une des manières d'y remédier est de
réapproprier son langage corporel et
enfin je vous dévoilerai comment
personnellement j'y suis parvenu pour
commencer la communication est un outil
formidable elle est au fondement de nos
interactions sociales cela dit la
communication lorsqu'elle n'est pas
assumée devient un véritable facteur
d'inégalité sociale nous avons tous et
toutes incorporer un certain languant un
certain langage depuis l'enfance on
reproduisant les propos de notre
entourage familial de notre milieu
socioculturel ce langage est et reste
une source d'inégalité sociale majeure
parce qu'il est rarement conscientisé la
plupart du temps vous n'êtes pas
conscient de vos types de langage vous
avez sans doute des amis qui parlent
extrêmement vite simplement parce qu'ils
craignent le silence le silence que je
vous invite à utiliser pour faire des
pauses pour aérer votre argumentaire et
pour éviter les fameux
avengirent bien entendu l'enseignement
scolaire en France a tendance à insister
sur l'importance des mots de la
grammaire ce qui est essentiel certes
mais oublie souvent le champ du
non-verbal or vous le savez le corps
humain a toujours été l'objet privilégié
de l'emprise sociale le corps humain
fascine d'autant plus à l'heure de la
culture de l'image il est donc
nécessaire mesdames Messieurs que vous
chacun et chacune d'entre vous puissiez
pleinement prendre conscience de l'atout
sans égal quelle évoquence votre
discours est le premier canal par lequel
la société se fait humilier de vous dès
que vous commencez à prononcer quelques
mots à votre intonation on devine on
devine facilement quel est votre niveau
d'instruction d'où venez qui vous êtes
si vous avez confiance en vous
votre voix vous raconte je vais vous
donner un exemple de la vie quotidienne
il m'est déjà arrivé de me retrouver
devant un guichet municipal comme chacun
et chacune d'entre vous et l'agent
administratif face à moi était assez
désapprobateurs face à mes parents
immigrés qui parlent bien moins beaucoup
moins bien français que moi il a fallu
que je m'avance et que je prenne la
parole pour soudainement débloquer la
situation soudainement par magie
débloquer la situation donc la parole
est un marqueur social oui mais utilisé
à bon escient elle est aussi une clé qui
ouvre la porte des possibles j'utilise
souvent la métaphore de la ligne de
départ nous avons tous et toutes ces des
parcours différents mais nous n'avons
pas tous commencé avec cette même ligne
justement chaque individu ne bénéficie
pas du même niveau de langue et
justement
l'enseignement de la prise de parole
permet de rééquilibrer ces inégalités de
départ au même titre que l'é criture
l'orale s'apprend et d'ailleurs à
l'heure où la rhétorique est devenue un
sujet grand public notamment grâce au
concours d'éloquence grâce au cinéma ou
youtuber mais aussi grâce au Ted
l'expression orale doit être un levier
de l'égalité des chances l'expression
orale et son enseignement doivent être
un vecteur d'égalité sociale
l'expression orale doit vous permettre
de provoquer la chance enfin
l'expression orale ne doit pas devenir
un simple écrit oralisé il ne s'agit pas
de rédiger le texte de son exposé de
l'imprimé puis de le lire à haute voix
avec précipitation devant ses camarades
il s'agit d'incarner son texte en tant
qu'aurateur vous êtes à la fois auteur
compositeur et interprète de votre
propre œuvre pour remédier à cette
inégalité de communication est de se
réapproprier son corps et de prendre
conscience clairement que notre langage
corporel forge qui nous sommes il y a un
concept de sociologie que j'aime bien
c'est le pouvoir symbolique
c'est l'idée que les modes de domination
sociale agissent sur les représentations
et les actions des individus dit dominés
je dis souvent que la discipline du
corps donne à l'orateur un pouvoir
symbolique c'est-à-dire qu'à partir du
moment où vous maîtrisez votre langage
corporel et que vous êtes capable de
l'utiliser pour appuyer vos propos vous
êtes dans une position symbolique qui
vous permet de persuader plus
ingénieusement votre interlocuteur
pour vous donner pour vous donner un
exemple il m'est déjà arrivé dans
certaines situations scolaires ou
professionnelles de ne pas du tout être
en position de force voir d'avoir tort
sur un sujet mais le fait que je
maîtrise mon langage verbal et non
verbal que je sois totalement à l'aise
en réalité provoquer un retournement de
situation où je me retrouvais en
position de force pour vous livrer ma
double technique favorite je vous
conseille de fixer le destinataire dans
les yeux pour ne pas vous déconcentrer
et en même temps d'ignorer totalement
les expressions faciales qui sont à vous
si la personne sourit rigole peu importe
pour ne pas être déstabilisé vous
comprenez donc votre langage corporel
forge qui vous êtes
le langage corporel affecte la manière
dont les autres nous perçoivent mais
cela peut aussi changer la façon dont on
se perçoit soi-même à titre personnel je
m'entraîne souvent devant un miroir la
première fois c'est assez étrange de se
regarder soi-même mais en réalité vous
vous rendrez compte que votre miroir
deviendra votre meilleur allié car il
permet rapidement de se corriger demain
après-demain je vous invite à faire
attention à la manière dont vos amis vos
proches ou vos professeurs s'expriment
vous vous rendrez alors peut-être compte
que certains s'expriment de manière
atypique en mettant leurs mains dans les
poches en croisant les jambes en se
grattant la tête
vous vous rendrez compte que 7% de la
communication est verbale c'est-à-dire
par la signification des mots 38% de la
communication est vocale et 55% de la
communication est totalement visuel ce
qui comprend les expressions du corps et
du visage ce n'est pas mathéori c'est la
théorie du psychologue Albert mirabian
qui l'utilise comme règle des 3V verbale
vocal visuel cette théorie intéressante
parce que elle peut s'appliquer aux
discours politique mais elle est sujette
à débat parce que d'une part si on prend
le cas de cours magistraux a priori vous
êtes totalement captivé par les propos
de l'enseignant donc la théorie des 7%
de communication verbale ne tient pas
d'autre part si je prends l'exemple de
notre soirée Ted il est possible que
d'ici quelques semaines vous ne vous
souveniez pas exactement de mes propos
ou des propos de mes collègues mais
plutôt de l'éthos général que les
speakers ont pu dégager et donc en ce
sens
la règle des 55% de communication
visuelle s'appliquent tout à fait
d'ailleurs on dit souvent que un
discours l'efficacité d'un discours
tient à trois éléments le Logos le
pataud et les TOS le logo c'est la force
de conviction par le raisonnement la
logique le pathos c'est je dirais la
manière dont l'orateur parvient à
susciter une émotion auprès du public et
les taux ce qui nous intéressent
maintenant ici c'est la crédibilité que
l'orateur inspire au c'est ce qui permet
de devenir une figure d'autorité c'est
ce qui permet de rendre un tribord
disons agréable et vivre de respect
l'éthos passe nécessairement par la
maîtrise du langage non verbal par la
réappropriation de son corps et c'est
d'ailleurs en maîtrisant votre épouse
que vous développez votre pouvoir
symbolique votre aura votre service
alors à ce stade vous allez me demander
comment je fais pour prendre conscience
de mon corps ça va et ce n'est pas une
question évidente donc personnellement
je travaille c'est en travaillant ma
respiration que je prends conscience de
mon corps donc pour vous donner un
exemple assez simple la première chose
que je fais c'est que je m'enfonce
doucement sur le fauteuil sur lequel je
suis assis je sens mon dos au contact du
fauteuil du dossier je prends quelques
respirations puis
je détends mes épaules on les rabaissant
je détends ma mâchoire mon coup et
j'imagine qu'une goutte de pluie glisse
de mon crâne au bas de mon dos mon corps
doit être disponible souple je me
redresse j'inspire tu expires
2 3 4
ce rituel peut paraître simple et
basique mais en réalité il est
fondamental fondamental parce qu'il est
grand votre corps relâché et présent
alors il est vrai que mon passé de
danseur m'a permis d'avoir une forte
conscience de mon corps il est vrai que
avoir été habitué à être sur scène à
s'exposer au regard du public à utiliser
l'espace à contrôler ma respiration tout
cela aide pour améliorer sa prestation
orale dans mon expérience de l'opéra à
Sciences Po je me suis rendu compte que
la danse et l'éloquence était en réalité
tu es très proche de la même manière que
le danseur communique par son corps sur
scène l'orateur est aussi un personnage
sur une scène qui s'exprime lui avec son
corps et ses mots la danse et
l'éloquence peuvent paraître des
vocations divergentes mais en réalité
elle constitue elle constitue chacune
une performance scénique où l'on met son
corps en jeu et c'est d'ailleurs en
partant de ce constat que j'ai décidé en
2020 de créer un programme pédagogique à
Lyon art oratoire et art vivant
en parcourant un certain nombre de
lycées je me suis rendu compte que le
grand aura le grand oral du baccalauréat
n'était pas suffisamment travaillé du
point de vue oral paradoxalement et
c'est dans ce cadre là que j'ai fondé
donc le programme dans ces loquence qui
consiste en des ateliers de formation à
la prise de parole destinée à des
lycéens de terminale en Île-de-France et
l'oxygiène de ce projet était justement
de faire directement appel à des
artistes de la scène tels que musicien
chanteur danseur contacteur acteurs qui
sont par définition des spécialistes de
la performance orale se tenir droit être
vertical et respirer
occupez l'espace marcher soudainement
disperser son regard tout cela ce sont
des compétences issues initialement du
spectacle vivant et qui se
retranscrivent dans la prise de parole
je me souviendrai toujours de cette
première sensation authentique sur la
scène de l'Opéra Garnier quand j'avais 9
ans seulement 9 ans face à 2000
spectateurs plongés dans le noir
le sentiment d'être sur scène est unique
et c'est justement en s'exposant au
regard des autres en sortant de sa zone
de confort en prenant confiance en
maîtrisant justement son langage
corporel et en montant sur scène que
l'on gagne confiance en soi la danse
était en quelque sorte ma première
chambre et l'éloquence ma deuxième
chance celle qui m'a permis après une
grave bien sûr de reprendre de reprendre
des études et de m'intéresser à cette à
laboratoire qui est devenu maintenant
une passion la performance orale je m'en
suis rendu compte constitue en quelque
sorte et tout autant qu'un ballet une
oeuvre d'art éphémère mouvante vivante
j'avais d'ailleurs un professeur de
musique qui nous avait donné un conseil
à l'Opéra il nous disait d'imaginer que
notre voix et notre regard
propulse des tâches de peinture sur
chaque personne du public il nous disait
d'imaginer que les spectateurs
au début revêtu de blanc se retrouvent
totalement coloré à la fin du speech
finalement si on résume la communication
et effectivement un facteur d'inégalité
sociale majeur une solution est de se
réapproprier son corps de se rendre
compte que notre langage corporel fort
qui nous sommes langage verbal et
langage non verbal sont donc
indissociables et complémentaires et je
suis d'ailleurs sûr que si on refaitait
le jeu de la balle tout de suite tout le
monde se regarderait instinctivement
dans les yeux
vous comprenez donc en quoi prendre la
parole c'est afficher son identité
s'exposer se révéler et c'est
effectivement en trouvant votre voix
Vox c'est à dire en travaillant votre
langage corporel votre prise de parole
que vous trouverez votre voix voie que
vous vous alignerez avec vos valeurs
propres que vous aurez constamment de
l'ambition dans tout ce que vous faites
et que vous vous sentirez légitime à
votre place
la parole est une arme redoutable une
force exceptionnelle une exigence mais
dans le même temps la parole est
également une bouée de sauvetage elle
permet la survie la sauvegarde la
deuxième chance elle permet de changer
un destin parfois
dès demain faites de votre parole votre
priorité numéro une parce que c'est par
elle que le monde vous découvrira pas un
jour ne passe sans que nous ayons à
défendre une idée un projet un produit
et à nous protéger contre des éventuels
fourberies
l'argumentation vous donne un pouvoir
mesdames messieurs à vous désormais
d'apprendre à le maîtriser et de savoir
irrésister
merci à vous et très bonne soirée
[Applaudissements]